we got joe carnahan in the house who who
is got we're gonna talk about El Chicano
your movie Oh in New York Times huge
feature on Chicano really oh yes now so
we're gonna get into that we're gonna
get into boss level yes well whilst Will
Sasso Mel Gibson Frank Grillo yes Naomi
Watts never heard yes Naomi Watts oh I'd
never heard of any of those actors yes
and and this is the guy who writes and
directs and if you guys don't know wrote
and directed smokin aces loved 18 top
five for me smokin aces great movie but
great that's why Brenda shelves a rich
guy well has a lot to do get into his
him being a baron a CVD Baron and it
will also get into the fact that well
you wrote and directed an arc you wrote
and directed the grey you wrote and
directed I mean I don't know how many
movies you have your hands on well it's
so no pride and glory
I'm glory for a good friend Gavin okay
yeah if so many movies Death Wish which
I I complained about until I saw a
residual check and stop complaining
about moving boy I remember that yeah
you're a very temperamental guy you
walked off a Mission Impossible when
you're attracting you were gonna direct
it with Tom Cruise yes that's good story
yeah he basically was I'm not doing the
movie told Tom yeah but you know what I
thought it listen it was just not my jam
Will Smith on bad boys three wasn't my
jam
they're great guy yeah we're you suppose
you could I was I was I did all Chicano
I was doing I was doing bad boys 3 and I
left bad boys 3 to go to El Chicano how
but was bad boys 3 why would you leave
it is just not it was just that's what I
call like the movie star Mambo like you
know will is a big guy moves a lot of
air and and you know you want certain
things done you you know you got to go
along with that yes yeah not who you are
that's how a lot of guys are though I
mean like so the big boys who move right
yes sir Martin Lawrence was just happy
to have a job listen I was a huge Martin
Lawrence fan back that I loved his shiny
too so I was bummed about not being able
to work with Martin Lawrence houses so
it was just one of those things man I
wrote what I thought was a fantastic
script it was greenlit in November of
2015
damn a while ago and then I get and then
I began that that process of what I did
with Tom where you go through and you
just starts getting pulled apart like
hot bread and it's like and that's okay
it listen if I was a 27 28 year old kid
like yeah whatever you wanna do ya know
I'm all the [ __ ] I'm not gonna you don't
they there but you I do care that's the
problem care about yours if you shut up
if I shut my mouth and wasn't such a
loudmouth that didn't say stupid ass
things throughout my career I'd be a lot
richer by Evie you know or he wouldn't
be here or I wouldn't be also wouldn't
be the artist you are you wouldn't be
the guy who can write a [ __ ] script
like smokin aces where I call you up and
I go hey how do you so cool so many
different characters like I'm really
proud of that film and it's but again
it's one of those movies not like like
with this one felt Chicano say I want it
now I just want to own that stuff I
don't want to work for hire why is this
el Chacal thing is kind of historical a
little bit right yeah it's an all Latino
cast and everybody passed on the movie
every passed on the script even though
they said all the scripts really good
and then everybody passed in the movie
when was dongok skins are so hot right
and I heard I heard someone say forgot -
isn't it me on the streets that sees on
the street all the craze let me get in
there I don't get on that mexic is it
the first Mexican is it the first
Chicano um so first it's the first yeah
it's well I think Ghost Rider was
written as no no no but really Nikkei
Nic Cage movie star Trump's any kind of
politically correct like oh they wanted
Joaquin Phoenix to play Pablo Escobar
I'm never meeting with Joaquin Phoenix
in New York to play Pablo Escobar thank
God we didn't do that but I worked with
him for five days he's a hell of an
actor but Pablo's where he died I work
with Pablo Escobar and Joaquin Phoenix
but different times but different time
different eyes bro back when I was in
the house in the cartel in the cartel in
Michigan 18 and cut the hair now you
know what's it got a henna
so is it is that the your movies
actually comprised of actual because the
story is based around Mexicans right
brother George there's no been brain of
the writer/director his brother he lost
him to gang violence and so he freaked
but he for years he said to me hey dude
there's no Latino superheroes there's no
we don't have our I don't identify with
a white guy and of cave black people
just out of black panther
and by the way showed up and so what it
wouldn't be what it was was he just said
he said that for years and years and
years and then he had a tragedy he lost
his daughter at birth and I'm like homie
listen and that's the [ __ ] most
inconceivable thing you know so I didn't
know how to how to deal with that how do
you deal with that level of tragedy just
go do if we can reconstitute this into
something creative and going make out
Chicano we should go do it and I was
kind of at the end of my rope with bad
boys 3 you know it's like you know
there's great stories about them you
know and I like I said I adore will and
and and it's his face on the poster his
name on a poster you got to do they want
away so looking you guys are similar you
guys are both alpha when it comes to
being creative so he's like you lab my
way you're like why mine you got Jerry
Bruckheimer Jerry Bruckheimer is no
slouch Jerry Rucka I'm not kidding you
we're on the ascent out of Burbank to
fly to Miami we're like this in Jerry's
jet and Jerry turns most [ __ ] around
we'll just give him what he wants I'm
like bro are you [ __ ] me door opens
and they got two thugs bathroom brothers
these two cotton you know but but it's
like but that's the level of and I love
Jerry man I mean Jerry zip I mean look
at in terms of successful producers
who's better who's more prolific up
there but but again man you're doing you
gotta be willing to play that game
I don't know how guys like JJ Abrams do
it they're just incredibly astute they
know how to balance out that studies -
take the the creative stuff from the
executives and just met he's they're
brewing at that is it is it a Marvel
guys I don't know they do but do you
think that Will Smith and Tom Cruise do
they then Brad Pitt I keep hearing that
the the age of the movie star is done it
is brother it is here's the truth and
think about it and these are gonna I say
this with all deference and would to
their talent and all respect if Hugh
Jackman doesn't have claws no one gives
a [ __ ] if Daniel Craig is a named James
Bond no one gives a [ __ ] if Robert
Downey jr. is a Tony Stark Nolan's the
characters the carrots like Marvel you
could test in anybody Batman Joker it
does not go off those things I mean
think about people show up to the
Avengers because [ __ ] so or them
whatever that his name is place Chris
house
it's great - he's great America they
don't they want to see the character
they want to settle not matter they
engage the brand the money it made
because it's certainly that cast helps
they're all great in their roles like I
love although I mean they're really you
know those and those movies are
intensely enjoyable but it decide you're
absolutely right brother that age is
over in like when people say well Lupita
Nyong'o a big star because US made one
hundred and seventy eighty million
dollars though she's a great actress in
a great movie and it worked
yeah but you can't you're talking studio
way of doing things is dying yeah over
well a lot of it too is going I just
having this conversation the other day a
lot of it's going digital
obviously digital's the move right yeah
so let's say I don't so let's say spike
wants to give you a TV show mm-hmm well
in four years spikes can be in your
space of digital so why would you give
them the right to your twelve part
series that you created when they want
to come into the space so now they're
gonna be competitors right now they're
on TV so they're not a competitor cuz
you're in digital right soon they're
gonna be over in regional right so why
would you know so what put on your
platform right that's not a right or
page that's exactly right their
competitors listen they said all those
baby see holy Marvel ho like Tommy
central those gonna be your competitors
and five yeah you know right now we're
cool in digital yeah gotcha you don't
have a place it I was thinking gonna
come over he pulled over YouTube they're
gonna come over to our oh [ __ ] I have to
channel but which is great for us
because we were already here yeah so but
if NBC or Comedy Central's do a TV show
why would you give it to them I don't
you just do it produce it yourself yeah
that's what we did cuz that O'Connell
listen it's like you look at that you
look at the statistics 7% of the tickets
purchased asian-americans 10% of tickets
purchased african-americans 25% of the
tickets Latinos out of John Woo film
like that it's close to fifty so if you
don't even have to look like I look at
that and go why would I give this why
would I sell this IP to a studio yeah
why would I just sell it I did was
smokin a so I don't know smoking is I
wish I did I to market the hell out of
it yes you know so and what Brendan just
says absolutely true I wondered why the
almost Marvel series Punisher Derrida
why they I thought were they must have
not gotten the
numbers they got cancelled now Disney
took them back because Disney's going to
launch against their own digital and so
is Apple so say I don't want to do they
want their stuff BAM yeah so everybody's
gonna be competing with Netflix yeah
it's all everyone
oh that this is the move all right and
then everyone's moving their the
streaming services are gonna be I'm
telling you streaming services are like
the new studio like that's where
although that's where all the hubbub is
gonna so it you want as much content as
you can be
yeah you want as much content people
come to your platform yeah yeah you do
why would you why would you give the
platform the economy central yeah yeah
at this kind of station other days he
comes this big network was like oh we're
gonna advertise in your podcasts cuz
they start a pockets a network you would
definitely know they what they want to
advertise in your podcasts got three
letters in it you start try one so I
went I went well what podcasts they have
and they gave me a list so I looked at
my with my shows bacon authors I can't
but build advertise your showing you
advertise on you know vice versa we you
you help them out they help you like
well only one person's helping so in
there yeah yeah just trying to get in my
space
yeah I'm TV yeah you guys kill me but
I'm digital I'm the big dog here right
and they just they want to advertise
because you guys they want they built
that audience that that audience at
loyal audience Jota Lee who's gonna
happen with your movie so I mean I mean
the thing is to it's like listen like 20
years ago and I started if you got a
two-picture deal Universal you were the
man it's like oh my god
you're anointed that's it it's
indentured servitude it's it's not
you're not really you know I'm listen
that's not to say like those guys like
you know they make the Fast and Furious
everybody's making a lot of money on
those movies every is making money on
the Marvel films everybody but at the
end of the day you're still at the
service of a giant you know monolithic
conglomerate yes you know what I mean
and you just got to decide and I think
what Brendan saying is very sharp very
smart because you just why I own it why
would I what I'll tell you what I'll do
I'll license it to you you only want to
license my show you wanna license that
great but I'm not gonna Dean Devlin
who'd produced his show called leverage
with Timothy Hutton which is not even on
the air anymore I can't find five people
have ever seen this show no my buddy was
with Dean when TBS literally was TBS one
of the handed him a 65 million dollar
check
why because Dean Devlin shot that show
himself cut that show himself and
literally sent it out to him an ISDN
line go
there's your show and licensed it to him
for seven years it's the 65 million
dollars and he would she shot in
Portland Oregon and literally used to
distribute all the per diem to the to
the cast and crew in two dollar bills so
that everywhere they went in Portland to
have to a merchant they went oh you pay
$2 bills you must be part of that show
so every time it came up for vote it
would pass the referendum to keep the
little tax Wow
smart that's that those are the guys
those are the world I think thought the
whole landscape in it's nothing it's not
that these big networks you know they're
stuck in their ways everything changes
right everything yeah evolve so I like
like with my County special jobs many
17th - shameless bike but when it drops
May 17th
like I'm going over with the publicist
some think they want me to do even that
plans old school like or I can just call
my friends who have a network when
they're my best friends they have the
biggest shows in the world I used to do
that this reach this many people that's
right this will be four days now you
want me to fly to New York and do all
that well how many people does that
reach man yeah in the you know they're
like well that's just I'm like well
that's what you're used to doing that's
the that's the mold but that's so old
school
is do it and some I've got my time can
you be so much more wisely than what you
guys are doing yeah that's so old school
yeah yeah but they're just stuck in it
right it just they don't know it's the
only thing they have to offer actually
well it's all but it off they thought
they know yeah you know it's just really
interesting to me that the creators now
for the first time in the history of all
the world are gonna have all the power
fantastic it's democracy because we
should not only that though you won't
have to worry about see cuz now when you
go to a friend of mine just interviewed
it Netflix and it is so worth there yes
oh can it they're like you're either on
board with this vision of ours which is
this new progressive vision right so
they actually have quotas where they'll
be like regardless of who's the best guy
for the job here or gal for the job we
want an Asian director we want a woman
of color here we want so you still gonna
check little box they want to check all
the boxes let me show you our video the
old studio is dead but but the problem
is that that that now you're at the
mercy of Netflix is you know Netflix
corporate board and whoever they aren't
whether then far left whether whatever
they might be right but I feel like it's
going to be interesting to
see how now when you have all the power
and it's up to your vision and you can
find your own your because we can kind
of say anything we want on this podcast
I still have in fact if we're
politically incorrect
nobody's gonna shut us down [ __ ] you
we've got we've got the work we've got
how many people what happens anytime a
sponsor or
someone around skills dude I really
shouldn't think you should censor we go
like this go [ __ ] yourself yeah which is
brilliant always go [ __ ] look as well
that's the ultimate because you have
kind of gestures that I don't give a
[ __ ] what I say you don't like it you
know freedom it's kind of a new freedom
controlled and could put anybody he
wants on that show any I don't always
agree with who he puts on there but it's
like goo everyone's whatever you want
because when you look when you look at
the sheer numbers of even this
podcasters [ __ ] Brogan's
it's the biggest show in the world man I
mean there's you can't go on Jimmy
Fallon Kimmel Colbert get more in
America that these podcasts reach more
people they touch more people at all
those shows you're right this because by
the way they don't they don't I don't
stay up to watch Fallon or Kim I don't
you know it's like in but again going
back to what you said if I don't need
that that is that outmoded outdated
antiquated way of thinking about how do
we promote this what do we do let's go
to this talk show this talk show this
talk let's get this cover of this
magazine magazines give me a [ __ ]
break who goes and goes oh I gotta get
that new vogue because blah blahs on the
cover promoting this movie it is it's
it's a ephemeral moment well they wanted
me to do they wanted me to do for
complicated Apes they wanted me to go
into five minutes on Fallon and five
minutes on and I was like for me yeah
four minutes of clean work later I was
like I don't I can just put this on
youtube
I can just put this out you know
elsewhere which I do I don't know that
that's gonna make any difference at all
it's not I in terms of people buying
there's no more Carson knows no more
like exactly a brushes Hank Carson's
make or break there's only three shows
yeah you have to prove from Carson your
career was set right now the clothes
thing you have to Carson is Joe Rogan
right he not bigger sheltered or yeah
I'm a but now it's not is not wrote like
you know with Carson if you had to get
set he'd go like this or invite you over
well now it's dictated by the fans row
he likes you if he's gonna have you on
yeah his fanbase dictates whether they
like it they give these items up with
them yeah like Julius Caesar yes as it
should be we say that on this show like
we say we have a lot of people who want
to come on and we know like there are
people good good people but I've said to
them now I just say straight I go you
don't want come on our show they go why
and I even actors on my TV show on
school and I love them but I'm like you
can't come on I said this too I won't
let AJ em I won't let my buddy Brett
Dyer I love them too much they're too
sweet it's not their eye but it's not a
fish that snot what we do our fans like
our fans would be like get the [ __ ] out
shows your kids whatever they might be
the guy kids not what we do right you
gotta be you gotta be a certain correct
they don't like that that's the thing
it's like it's like you gotta be willing
to speak your mind to it's like because
this cuz I'm telling you it's that
system of kind of [ __ ] like
publicists and this that don't do this
don't do that's like for who for what
yeah people like nah [ __ ] look at the
country living right you have to be I'm
worried about what you're saying get the
foot come on stop with that it has to be
authentic because we've taken away that
wall like before back and they like
Arnold Schwarzenegger search Sloane a
Steven Seagal Romero those were the guys
yeah yep over it but you it you just
knew them from that you didn't know
there was a million
they were unicorn yes you saw me come
like wonderful while we beg he's gonna
be on or you'd see like maybe a picture
of him eating like holy [ __ ] eat food
like I know I know now that wall
separate gone you know whose bet the
best at it is Will Smith he went hold on
Instagram is the way people get to know
you
yeah oh cool hold my [ __ ] beer yeah
you want like show everyone how to do
Instagram yeah and he has a team right
form yeah he put all this effort and
Instagram now I kill [ __ ] wheels great
oh yeah wheels great right is he got is
he got a huge following yeah very big
good friend by far the best lens I mean
he's putting time into it he's Olivia's
riders by the way and I said to these
guys are land like the whole stuff all
the stuff with is 30 million good beyond
all the all the stuff with will like I
said like with like what everything
anything on any kind of [ __ ] I talk like
I was waiting for somebody to say you
shouldn't say this about about your time
with way
do this [ __ ] I said hey man I gotta [ __ ]
it's you know seven million dollar movie
opening it's fight week I'll give you
[ __ ] who I said what about a group
calling you out right yeah its market
fight week so come for me bro yeah boss
level though this this movie you did
with with Mel Gibson with Naomi Watts
yeah Frank Grillo
yeah that's Will Sasso I've heard
there's the will that's do I know I've
heard Natsu I'm not from you I've heard
from people who are like dude this is
gonna be the this movie is I guess
they're freaking out about it are the
studio's all [ __ ] tonight look at I
look like I look like something's wrong
I look like I have Bell's Paul no you
look good great picture of guys and let
me could look at that [ __ ] come on you
look like the young guy like died to
happy be here uh uh yeah it's not a good
help Mel's a trip he's malice let me
tell you something one of the most
misunderstood and [ __ ] and a
talented guy that we're still gonna kind
of that this guy still dealing with this
[ __ ]
after going sober apologize you like
doing this thing all he did he sugar
tits thing it's like oh you're still
it's like let me tell you something
we're done if this unless the society
has completely abandon any measure of
forgiving well they have that he's so
working though yes I love them not you
know listen thank you take a seat for
ten years yeah as we're happy you said
that yeah said listen I knew I was gonna
I knew I was gonna get blacked out
pretend I knew I was going hey dude you
gotta take years they say with the sugar
tits it was an anti-semitic rant I mean
you know it was and there was also the
other thing about the black there was
the I've been heard there was a sign
there was a couple of unfortunate
incidents he gets very truck but but but
you know what message all the guy and by
the way you notice it's like there's a
great it's like there's a great story my
brother's reading this thing a Chekhov
are I think it tells his story about
like che was a kid and Argentina and
he's driving through the countryside he
was from means his dad was it was before
he became a sociopathic murder his dad
was a doctor and we ever had a car and
our GT at that time nobody had a car and
he catches sighted shaved making fun of
like the bike like the peasants work in
the fields he pulls a car he grabs him
at some other road sizes don't you ever
think you're better than anybody talent
is the only aristocracy and I [ __ ]
love that I think Mel is room absolutely
part and parcel that statement hit
talent yeah he's a fantastic director
Apocalypto dude they attach on the cries
yeah
has he done in rave heart rave heart
Sauvage oh by the way always this series
daddy's a race he's a race he'd been
Apocalypto they spoken I mean they spoke
an ancient like give a get out of your
mouth [ __ ] hey I adore him you know I
heard the story about yeah yeah he said
have a problem with alcohol and he would
go a little crazy I guess he throw
weapon lethal weapon oh yeah he'll tell
you stories he'll tell you stories about
her steam her stories like the old days
a Hollywood like Christie's living in a
room by him and his other handsome
Australian friend and then Andy Warhol
just peek around a curtain take a
picture and then just appear back behind
a curtain and then over here there's
Warhol again like I mean it's the best
they tells the best story yeah it is Mel
all good in the in the head is he best
yeah he's also nortis
Mel's a hyper hyper bright guy he's your
scene dude there's a moment on the since
by the way he dislocated Frank's during
the fight he dislocated Gorillaz jaw
just looked at out of out of place
they'd to reach it Frank's mouth the
literally like like pop his job back yet
he's the kind of guy who like I had a
bullet in there where the signs yeah
he's the kind of guy who does this tell
correctly the wrong right everything he
does is that content to [ __ ] like he'll
he's eating I'm we're talking and
because I was right next to him I
basically was there for three hours and
he wouldn't even taste he's eating
putting butter on his bread knees goes
and he takes his thing's gonna and then
he goes smell that why cuz he can't
drink let me smell that because I swear
to god he's got the forum's he's
literally Julian Rosen yet she's
gorgeous beautiful and she's a writer
that he's directing your next movie yeah
I bet he's a fantastic writer yeah yeah
but but but it's like but you but you
look at a guy like Mel and you go that
guy's that guy's a monarch that guy's
that guy's one of those dudes like Frank
and I
a couple times are like it's it's it's
it's it's Mad Max I mean it's it's it's
Martin Riggs from lethal weapon that's
Riggs
it's Riggs - so yeah man he he is he is
one of my favorite people and and and by
the way you get a call like I got from
Mel Gibson if I'm awesome and you never
forget it man and then Stallone calls
you saying Mel said hey Jose slide Mel's
talking about you might want to talk to
you but I mean it just is [ __ ] great
that's a great marker ah come on which
is like would like these are my
childhood come out I don't know
tonight is a big screening tonight the
Grove they're screening the movie and
I'm not going anywhere near it because I
just don't want to be there this little
dude you know you dude I used to like
you know I don't want to read anything I
don't senior reviews I don't wanna stay
I just want to see numbers I want to see
bar I don't give a [ __ ] you you want to
die down this rabbit hole you know some
idiot in Wichita doesn't like am I gonna
do my job you it's like the screenings
for the studio heads screenings for all
the studios
so CAA is putting it on you and these
guys are murderous you know rampaging
Marauders either SAS I love it so you
couldn't and and it's and it's listen it
is a it is a absolute people towards a
game changers against Frank guerrillas
career in life ain't gonna be the same
after this movie he does something
extraordinary in that film he's in Italy
right now shooting with Ryan Reynolds
yeah he's the bad guy in hit man's
bodyguard - so he but he Frank did
something they're scenes cuz I he'll
admit this but he got a squeezed out he
didn't want to Rio his son of the movie
and he called casting and said you can't
put me I know Joe wants Rio in the movie
we can't he's never acted before Bubba
that kid steals every scene he's in with
his dad Wow and you know it's amazing
you think about you think about your
child right you look at that kid in a
way that I don't care the best child
actor in the world correct you're never
gonna look at that kid the way you do
your own flesh of life so those scenes
with them it's like our DP said that
movies funny as [ __ ] until it's not and
then it's even better can you tell us a
little bit about what that with this
right now
Frank is it's kind of it's like
Groundhog Day me to die hard yeah so how
so when he wakes up instead of like
what's happening to me the shit's
already happened to him 140 times so he
knows this guy that he calls mr. good
mornings
wake him up the girls gonna scream this
girl he was with the night before he
wakes up the guy swings a machete in his
head he blocks it he knows exactly what
he's gonna do
hits him with the coffee waits rob
gronkowski comes up in a helicopter with
a side mounted like you know groggy gun
Kronk lights the place up kills the guy
Frank takes a knife throws into his head
helicopter comes in the end of the thing
he's sitting there very quietly wait for
anything happened they look seeded it he
gets up jumps out the window lands his
sand truck at the right time all the
shakes timed everything out and he's
like and all he does is go to so when
this happens the only his only recourse
is I go to the same bar the same lake
Chinese restaurant run by Ken Jeong
Michelle Yeoh is in there I go to the
same place I wait I get drunk these
people show up and they kill me and I've
never lived past 12:47 p.m. ever and so
that's the basis of the film okay and
then Naomi Watts places his ex-wife was
a physicist and they have a son and so
on a sober and so then he gets he
started he realizes wait a minute this
has somebody with her but she's been
killed by Mel Gibson's character and but
you know what's Gronk like croc was
great me Gronk's like a giant
six-year-old that is just a giant frat
boy yeah oh yeah so funny and so like we
all whatever you know like he just he's
just make sense you know what I mean you
know you're retired huh yeah I wonder if
that's because he wants to get in the
movies I think so
I think so but listen he was dynamite
and in that cast are our dear friend
Will Sasso well hell yeah last was so
good man he's got a couple scenes that I
shot a scene with him and I said alehrer
is like a two-shot aimin mouth and I say
bro you're the only actor in the history
of movies that was in a scene with Mel
Gibson where he was out of focus
I kept will and focused the whole whole
shot and all you do is hear Mel behind
him talk and Mel's out of focus the
whole moment I was like Sasso
congratulations bro you've blown a
[ __ ] Club one upstaged mental
upstaged Mel
yeah so yeah so tonight's a big night
all right and I'm not gonna go anywhere
near it I just want to stay back now
when you become when you become super
rich what are you gonna do how's your
life going to change well I'm gonna
super rich like child super wrecky Isis
CBT I mean Ferrari rich from multiple
Ferrari
have you settled on what Ferrari you can
oh man you know I got a tow car guy I
got a text from him and I think the 488
really is that the one you were leaning
towards yeah what is it
325 350 the 488 horsepower
no no no no dude cost Oh cost depends
he's gonna cost now he was going to talk
about one secondary yeah I would never
buy anything there's gone everybody knew
mm okay that's not right
no that you can't walk it's not you
cannot walk yeah and walk out it's over
three yeah it's three 320 there's a
waiting list you could do that again so
much on horses
I could why do you have so many horses
because my wife loves to ride horses
ones yeah she has that no no she has
next he's a couple bought the books like
she's got four now four or five but how
good she's tallies a great rider so yeah
you got to be a horse though you know
look at the McLaren good look at that
car man what would you rather have in
McLaren are Ferrari I mean MacLaren's
are listen dude I just telling you I
drew I'd ever driven that where I drove
the 458 it was the greatest automobile
I've ever sat it because you somehow
feel like you're hovering above the road
in a weird way man have you driven this
thing Brandon no Friday I go see you
have to wait have you driven the 458
well 450 a 488 when we left 12 he has a
what supports you have gt3rs
oh dude you got the one that weight
didn't have one kill Paul Walker similar
eyes yes I think you know which Paul
walk in a gt3 RS or Wadena a GT you
might be in that that boss one GT I
don't mean once I got the guys rag like
that's the one that killed me I got from
a jackass died in the GT yeah jackass
Ryan Ryan done died in a gt3 RS I think
just too fast too [ __ ] well Ryan Dunn
I'm not a I'm not a reckless driver now
it's not my so brother you can jump on
that car and get weird in like a split
second right but didn't see the but I
like I Drive my truck during the day to
back forth from we're gonna do stand-up
at night there's no one on the road so I
take the Porsche hatch yeah and I mean
they go down
yeah I'm eating row anything no not
around yeah you there's no no I just
blaze man right if I had man Amaris like
it's like I'm an amenities well I have
them [ __ ] yeah I had the Panamera GTS in
that car like it's a beautiful car dude
I mean ever seen that and that thing
just I mean I'll stick to my like I was
in the cars but I'm just no I'm not no I
don't cousin I spend more too much my
brother just bought a 442 what was it
old Cutlass convertible he loves those
he wants a super but he wants the old
like you know the Mona learn cars yeah
like the old super b27 like the
barrett-jackson always watching
barrett-jackson like what can I get off
barrett-jackson
not gonna tell you once mere Jack's in
there and make you want to buy some [ __ ]
they just have like a Firebird well they
just had you said Burt Reynolds Trans Am
to Dave's in the Hooper car way after
that they'll have like a Mercedes and
stuff like that I'd like an old Chevy I
know it's very strange i watch it late
at night I know I love it it's so
interesting to me that guys are so into
cars all Rogi and I talk cars for I
don't know 30 minutes just Ferraris yeah
cuz you know he's not a Ferrari guy yeah
he gets he got what is he on the IV owns
like 10 cars oh yes yeah I don't have I
got a no but I have an old stepside
Chevy truck that's like 521 horse it's
got a v8 like like the long walk it's
just a brutal machine and I've told
Frank Frank let me put the kids in the
bed with bro don't punch it because you
don't understand how fast this thing is
it's really fast and he did it and I Bri
almost like tumbled out of the back this
you burn them
I mean burn them like he's gloves like
for you and Frank have both have a
Hellcat yep or just we have to we have
to chopped like coupe Hellcats for there
are those the Dodge things yeah yeah I
died a Dodge thing all right those those
dogs I raced off the line with my test
that I beat them did you yes you catch
things I don't know dude
god damn man I don't know your tester
goes like what what is it like it comes
with tofu and eggs it doesn't matter he
comes tofu Crocs broken straight just
such a little limp dick run oh by the
way they have now they have the
hellephant which is the the what
elephant which is the hell elephant they
had that they had the demon and now they
had the hell of it which is 1200
spacially a Formula One car
dude see I like what
just doing their like okay everyone's
into the electric car and
environmentally safe cool we're gonna
double down yeah because we know there's
dudes out there that with your fat dicks
and big bank accounts wait hold on man
that's not fair that fat wallets and
want to buy a badass car dude that's
what that thing did I mean that always
not Steve McQueen's alive today and we
make when we drive in that car did my
testosterone just like yes and you know
me nothing gets really good when you get
your bro watch if you had to watch your
bullet in McQueen's and attest it's like
that's what's gonna sound like dude like
you know so that's what you that that
right there that that gets you going
oh yeah that's a guy I've never seen
that I've ever heard of it looks like
look up like male like this like a 69 1
Mustang this 9 Mach 1 must they do look
it I want that car so bad I like a
Mustang it's like it's like like you
know how when you walk like look at that
car you don't know what you know I'll
put a little you want a drop-dead
gorgeous girl like watch like you at
dinner and you know let's get pissed yes
yes [ __ ] yes I feel about certain cars
yeah it's amazing
get the girl thing my car I wonder what
that I wonder what the psychology is is
it because you want to have the most
powerful car on the road what is the
well not me though my brother last night
romance to it yeah there's sunlight when
it is a real mouthful childhood Roman
when I was a kid Mia
Ferrari port that was the [ __ ] like my
brother call me and just like he just
taught me how sign just talk [ __ ] on
Ferrari keys such a where Porsche family
he's always like send me videos and just
shitty go by like that gorgeous new
Maserati that Maserati is nice it's fast
but like I'm not I don't care what they
do on a race track record like yeah you
just love it into a piece of art yeah
yeah it's just in its kind of the same
reason you like fashion because do you
think about it you feel when you're a
kid did you ever think you don't a
Ferrari I don't think you don't have you
see the Lambos you see those kinda like
I mean you think about this it's it's so
funny how far we've come from like we're
kids it's like in the 80s you had a hot
in the bikini on the you know Nick next
to Freud next to Lambeau funny I was
thinking about this year today the ZZ
Top has been destroyed by that and I'm
looking the old like the old eliminar
like ZZ Top it's like what was it's like
you had beautiful women but it's like
now it's like verboten like it's
something you know you can't do that
anymore you can't really oh yeah like
it's in its cars bro you know I got
scared us girls see that it seems like
you say you can't do that now it's like
you can't that that's not cool anymore
because it's like well it's like I okay
subjective fine you know I was watching
the other day in the hotel room my
brother and I were it was in Phoenix
turn shows we're in the hotel room we're
watching Total Recall Total Recall Ramos
Nagar great movie there's no way can
make it today don't really like that oh
wait cuz we don'twe what he's in the
machining hits the pic it's fantasy
they're all do you like athletic curvy
skinny he's all athletic and then
they're all then they're all classy or
sleazies a sleazy thing and it's like
going through the girl and her tits and
our ass to have weird science where
weird science their building yeah you
know what's funny about that that's
gonna happen it's already happening with
like dolls and simulation you choose
what you want you can do it with porn
there they have all they're gonna
they're gonna customize that you can be
able to shape it like a look like an
Android so it may be politically
incorrect but I guarantee that's on its
way I just I want you know what you know
it's bothered it's like are we now going
to start Nate are we now going to censor
our past
of course historically already are going
to are we gonna mmm it's like I heard
there was there was a museum in Swift
and they were literally changing the
names of it was it was something like
little n boy which is I get it right but
this is 300 years ago dancing to little
dark boy dick like like are we gonna
revise it to the point where cool aliens
years from like thousand years ago wow
these people really progressed they
really were progressive they really were
ahead of it look what they did
I feel like goddamn it you can't like
I'm not saying listen I understand war
monuments right the Buffalo Bills don't
have monuments built to them because
they lost [ __ ] four Super Bowls okay
you lost what in the museum give it
context
that's that there's not like you know
there's nothing you know Marv levy
[ __ ] statue Buffalo yeah yeah you
don't get the robert e lee lost you
gotta go bro you know build statues to
that he was also fighting but key in
place exactly exact I'd be like I'd have
a bit funky [ __ ] statue out of here but
you know you do put in a museum I don't
care rednecks wanna give it some context
say this is what this guy did cuz this
is what happened rights still history so
it's our history it's ugly it's
uncomfortable it's awkward but don't
erase it don't erase it yeah that's lads
now that's more dangerous it's important
to no one you know what happened yeah
important to know that's exactly right
yeah you got a half the country fighting
to keep an institution like slavery in
place yeah because it was economically
viable yeah for them yeah so I still
find it weird that we're just gonna just
pass over the fact that guys are into
girls with fat asses and lots of
horsepower like we can't just
conversation about institutionalized
racism yeah because I'm in the greatest
segue Oh from first gear why because
they've done study after study with with
men who've been blind from birth and
they prefer they prefer a curvy
mannequin over a regular mannequin they
are they're sexually turned on they've
never seen a woman with their eyes right
they prefer the 3270 hip rate way closer
close your eyes and rev a Tesla and
close your eyes and rev a [ __ ] f12
Ferrari a v12 that's what I say yeah no
I that's the way we're going but here's
the thing there's a visceral reaction to
things right there's a there's a there's
a there's you feel it and it's like and
are we gonna are we trying to eliminate
that from are we gonna say you shouldn't
feel that way don't feel that way yeah
it's absurdist [ __ ] and by the way
it doesn't work anyway it would listen I
think the one maybe the only goddamn
good thing about Donald Trump is that
what he's forced society to do it's
[ __ ] fry whatever freak flag you
happen to own yeah
full master at least be yourself always
good or bad to give a [ __ ]
he says [ __ ] you're outrageous [ __ ]
they just could back up the [ __ ]
Brinks truck man but it's a it's like
expose whatever that is well be who you
are be who you are
adult word is regressive nonsense where
you get to censor every but the
regressive the sensor and like and you
see this be like when when you do shows
all over America during stand-up
somebody like dude you're a little
raunchy we'll talk about take stuff like
this well I see it in person thousands
of people that's that's when are they
love right my crowd is bro American
riding row wrecks and that were that's
what we like man it's if I don't go the
other way change depending you're meant
to let me change my sense of humor
because it's off-putting to this the
Sumari shove you start a stranger yes if
you start doing that [ __ ] all you're
gonna do is kind of milquetoast
neutralize every form of art there is to
be honest I don't know how to do it if
it should if Showtime put a gun in my
head Zhai dude you have should stop
talking about dicks I was fighting in
cars yeah in chicks by the way what did
were showing are we gonna fire like did
I'm yeah Chappelle says I have a rule
myself I never apologize for something I
say up yeah good for you that's exactly
he goes that hole goes in the hole
Caitlyn Jenner Bruce Jenner rant yeah
I'm not it's like the [ __ ] is from I
definitely making mistakes yeah not in
my stand-up but on you and on this show
I make a lot of noise can I try to hurt
people's feelings or Vietnam but I make
normlessness but sometimes you know we
just call it like it is - and you know I
think I think the problem is that there
are a lot of people who just are not
willing to look at what the reality of a
situation is when I see people actually
supporting Jesse small at and at living
sense I'm like come on dude come on hey
by the way come on here's the thing I
felt like an [ __ ] because I merely
cuz that's poor [ __ ] guy like these
[ __ ] um guys and then you
realize what this guy did and it's like
what the first tip-off should have been
his name's Jesse that's should be number
one well that's up number two is these
two rednecks in Chicago aren't watching
Empire no dude they're not did no one
think that that these you mean that why
Geryon
yeah yeah white guys supposedly are
watching Empire recognized it so weird
is it that's the first alarm first thing
we did we work both of us were like like
I - you give a 6-inch sub at 2:00 in the
morning and freezing cold Chicago you
still have the sub and white guys watch
imply we're [ __ ] in this whole thing
like that you know so the the Terry
Crews thing right it was interesting cuz
I have a friend who you know and he
knows Terry's super well and he knows
the agent super well and who grabs his
dick yeah so the agent was this was do
you know the story you know the details
of it heard the agent came up don't like
it but you got a fat hog so so the agent
was he's got five kids and he was so
dude she got he was so drunk ha ha he's
so drinking a party so drunk on this
party and he's walking around and he
just comes down I take her yes cousin
Tarantino says he knows he's his age is
he was his agent he was uh he was there
with a group and he knew him you knew
his part of blood like a senior for the
Brocade carry on so but it was at an
actress famous actors house and he he
was the agent was the actor sure I'll
tell you who all this later
like totally so um so apparently he just
comes up and he goes and grabs his neck
and he's drunk but he's doing it to
people so everybody yeah he's doing he's
like he be my friends do don't do and
who you know goes hey dude he goes with
a famous actor
he goes hey dude you gotta tell your
agent he's super drunk
he's a really good guy but he was he's
super drunk and behaving in a very
[ __ ] up way so any labels did so yeah
so so so then my friend so my friend
finds out that he grabs Terry's dong and
Terry's like uh [ __ ] you know so he
calls the agent the agent says I'm sorry
so sorry I'm Terry calls agent well no
the girlfriends big time next day yeah
yeah so now the act yeah agent your
proletariat do you grab a [ __ ] sample
card Terry goes listen I'm really sorry
are we cool and Terry goes yeah it's all
good man whatever you know so okay so
many dramas yes so it's all it is what
it is
you were [ __ ] drunk as [ __ ] you
grabbed my dick that well you know what
I do to play Batman
one of the biggest today she got a fat
hog you know yeah well you know this
agent was huge he was a huge agent yeah
yeah yeah grandma did it was Adam
Sandler's agent oh god dude rabbit grass
so now rabbit show us he calls him how
you guys butter it up Superman
grab it so he calls him up because my so
check this out
so the me to thing happens Oh two years
later two years later this is true bro
yeah
is this true years later than me two
things yeah Brian went landline now he
comes out and he goes by the way Wow and
now Time magazine dude you all time
magazine referred to him as one of the
silence break hey you're out you're not
you can't be on my island anymore you're
out I mean dude Island bro shut up I
mean you played pro football you're the
baddest myth because I couldn't hit
himself as a black man I get in trouble
listen listen take it easy
he was really [ __ ] up you know he's
not a bad guy
you know I'll so how old is he Johnny 15
right yeah like you're traumatized hamer
and this he said he said that boy he had
all the power here buddy who's in that
moment he had all the power
yeah and I'm like oh come on here's the
other thing Ted Cruz went on a [ __ ]
and now you to be sued him in that
lisa.marta
sued for sexual harassment and Terry
went on a PR [ __ ] whole campaign on
how he's addicted to porn you mean being
a dude
you wouldn't that was your that was your
crime that he was on Oprah crying listen
Oliver Reed famous Oliver Reed yeah used
to famously dick drop people at parties
meaning you put your martini glass down
you looked over all arenas dick in it
well he was charming to friends right I
put my balls in my friends drink I know
guys used a famous actor to show that
who shall remain nameless who's a buddy
of mine used to put his balls on top of
directive director fell asleep in his
chair
balls on his head take a picture right
we're gonna sum
gonna die yeah this is a dog what
happened to me I'm not gonna call my
agent like get ahold the publicist
someone grabbed my nuts the other day he
took a lot of [ __ ] from the rap
community
apparently Terry with RAM come here at
the rat a lot of rappers were like bro
you know everyone everyone in general
but I think well I'm this was Adam cried
about jet that you had to go to [ __ ]
therapy cuz you were addicted to porn
yeah he's your addicted I need it he's
also using language that's been given to
him from from the from the lawyers the
big the women's department of Yale in
that moment he had all the power in his
hand
and and and that was it took my power
from me oh my god dude come on I mean if
you're his teammate and pretty played
for the Chargers you managed for your
teammate like if let's say Klopp Klopp
some massive man let's say co-opted that
I saw in the club was famous I would
call my are you [ __ ] me dude are you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you're suing the agent for
grabbing your right but even if you have
any quote and said he had all the power
yeah but he'll call me even if I was
like say say you say you're drunk in New
York I don't know you're big and I know
you a little bit and I you can beat my
ass and I'm just gonna if you came up
and grabbed my dick I would be like I'd
be like [ __ ] a guy grab my dick with
a pun it's not
I'm sorry you swing on them if you're if
you're so if you are he said if you to
see one already lost his career which
well okay but here's here's my question
man and I see Terry Crews seems like a
great dude and he does and I'm trying to
end the day [ __ ] I'm not minimizing
whatever but but did you make the right
call in that moment are people now
ringing I don't know help your career I
assume most and I'm not and that's not
to say steak [ __ ] that's the last [ __ ]
no but what I'm saying is I feel like
guys guys who also not not this
testosterone-filled culture but I feel
like guys just like dude I can't [ __ ] I
can't work with that guy now such a
[ __ ] move yeah there's actual real
victims out there by the way what I
heard
woman who got grabbed by the pulse yeah
right now that's the victim yeah you're
6-3 250-pound shredded by the way you're
making all the way in the world by the
way the women that did go through that
[ __ ] the women they think about that and
I think about somebody like you know
Mira Sorvino who basically told how he
wanted to get [ __ ] I don't want to go
air was ruined and then Peter Jackson
calls her years later and says I'm sorry
I was gonna put you in Lord of the Ring
Wow
Harvey Weinstein shot you down different
animal did pronounce I'm thinking myself
[ __ ] that guy's like go away bro go away
that woman and I'm and again man like
nobody's got their he's got you done
done oh by the way out put them in I
don't give a [ __ ] like like that's a bad
bad bad bad person and that I don't like
got a sliding scale where do you put
that versus the tear but also it's like
but there's also like the cool thing to
do it's opportunity but it's the same
with comic certain comics that jumped on
louis c.k well now that waves kind of
over and then they're like oh [ __ ] i but
I still I still think he's [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] I don't use out that he could
sell out staples right I think I think I
think that stuff bigger than that I
think he could I think he I think on
that I think in the mass media side his
movie what I just think the TV
production yeah it's like this it's not
it's not gonna stand ups different
standards different like exactly
there is a clear he over vine yeah
listen dude Pibb
went with his is now on the on the
circuit doing stand-up right it's like
it this is a difficult [ __ ] time and
I don't think I'm telling you there is
there would be there be a at the
executive levels a pushback that it
would just be an oxy with that wasn't
easy but Lucy K doesn't need it because
Louie CK came out right
he lost tens of millions of dollars
because of what he did right so he paid
his dues yeah but also the other thing
is is his he's so talented his talent
was so undeniable as a stand-up the most
people like all right dude all right man
just dark yeah you start that's always
been your thing but not your really
famous people pay more attention to it
it's what he does they say he said what
do you guys want I've lost everything
and I get shouted out I get booed out
you want to take my birthday as well
yes - I think about birthday - I mean
listen I'm telling you there is a there
is a there was a trigger finger
reactionary thing with that I'm talking
about in the in television doesn't
matter how good his show was his show
was great right great doesn't matter how
it doesn't matter like his movies never
gonna get released when the actress is
coming out I figure the young actors -
movie says it should just go away you're
not gonna get your apologist you're not
gonna get sympathize no but could
because no one's gonna lean out and go
hey he's not so you're gonna get your
head on something but he got lumped in
with Harvey Weinstein he's not like yeah
when that was so hot to do his [ __ ] came
out right around then he got lumped in
with that horrible horrible [ __ ] yeah
and then he was so free then - he went
the Parkland kids now they got homie
that's a fuss about a bad look that's a
terrible look because if you're trying
to rebound you know go look like okay
let me do something equally horribly
egregious and take a shot these it's
like you know he's like that shot come
and go you've been doing it for years
but I'm so famous now write headlines
it's just also a session be recorded
it's crazy to finally listen it's crazy
we live in the age of Trump and there's
still people so wildly offended by [ __ ]
that's like contextualize you don't wait
guys come on let's let's measure the
outrage for a moment it's easier though
it's easier it's easier to you see it's
much easier you get points you get
social brownie points for finding the
racist or finding the second whoever it
is finding anybody offensive and
destroying but you only get the points
online if you go around America you're
not getting points by the way I had no
one's buying your shirt I had Noah's
mind clear on your show I had this woman
named Lexi Alexander she's a director
she's Palestinian German take a shot at
me and I mean a shot basically calling
me a racist this was a business somebody
I was kind of sociable with in it and
we're fellow filmmakers and so on and so
forth she took a shot at me saying
because I had watched this video of
Chelsea Clinton basically being
harrangue by this young woman's
Palestinian woman saying it was your
fault that the I forget what the
specific tragedy was has somebody goddam
shootings that these types of things
happen in the world and she's at this
forum that Chelsea Clinton started so
that these people could have this shared
dialogue right and I said something
Twitter like hey somebody got
slapped right and this woman comes at me
so hard with this racist almost
invective like like you're not gonna say
that about this person and I'm Palestine
I'm they hey chill the [ __ ] well she was
looking to aim at anyone she just wanted
you're a [ __ ] wacko yeah and I'm not
and I'm not taking a bait I just made a
movie with nothing but Latinos and I'm
not gonna sit here and pull my am i
racist card and yeah [ __ ] out at section
but you know it was it was deliberate
targeted outrage it's also also like see
cuz I was because I said I don't like
because that kids attitude to me sucked
yeah Sam Harris was saying if if you
call enough non racist racist and get
them fired like he would he dissected
the whole who is the guy at Netflix who
was saying let's not use the n-word and
he got fired and they knew they were
like he was saying not to use it and
that when you actually look at the
details of that it was just like you
guys are you're getting rid of somebody
who's not he's not he's saying let's not
say it didn't got you on your side by
the way just throwing [ __ ] off further
down let's tell people don't think this
don't think this don't think this and on
the flip side what you're seeing is the
reactionary thing in Trump with people
go go [ __ ] yourself I want to say
whatever I want that guy says whenever
he wants I'm tired of being the thought
police saying don't do this I gotta did
it you like curating every goddamn
comment that you make it's impossible
they're so ridiculous his deceptive use
of the n-word or at least two occasions
at work where it's like let's not use
the word shut unacceptably low racial
and awareness and think about it even on
set now would you be like whenever like
I was at the where was I last I was at
The Improv last night doing a set and
there's a female come before me I just
gave her a high five like I don't hug
you I don't because I'm worried about
I'm sure on set it's different yeah
before all this I'm sure you know girl
yeah fine I was Maria Pomona got put an
hour ago I don't do it I'm not sir
controlling this [ __ ] they are promised
that they get into PR they get into a
human resources departments at big
corporations yeah because they study
gender studies and they have nothing
else to do but be resentful activists so
now they get in there and they say cause
all these [ __ ] speech codes and all
kinds of stuff
they're basically tyrannical you know
they are lose the first person I saw
that you saw this movement coming
Ozzie had his history with the maid at
his house Arnold Schwarzenegger I went
to event he was at and there's all these
people taking pictures with him but he
wouldn't take a picture with just a girl
so if just a girl came up invite you you
better have a friend or male friend and
he really oh yeah Wow date with just one
girl right like you might leave here
then this say oh this is where I met him
was just me and him alone and you don't
have another no matter what I think I
see fries like this why see do they
still prior to run whoa dude this is 10
years ago like what's so period cuz he
ran it hard oh man are p2 in the paint
still 478 don't I mean Danny that looked
like a roll by the way so that go out in
Holland kid like it looks like him as a
Guatemalan like yes that kid is it's not
who's on Howard Stern is like worth it
was still trying to figure it out like
we you know I made mistakes ain't like
he's like you know me and the family and
the kids and then what's the kid's name
I forget because even him we're all
together as a family
I said I got to yeah he told me it like
a Samba had like dinner them and I go
and I kind of dude was jokingly said
we're talking about women or daughters
and I go well I just don't want my
daughter dating a guy like me and he
goes that's right kid it's so weird cuz
then the rest of his kids don't look
like him at all so for this one yeah
right look at dude come on do it do it
you could do it I'm not doing it I'm
here that's awesome man though that's
awesome but here's the thing
all's forgiven made all is forgiven
by the way cuz you know what
Schwarzenegger went yeah I mean what he
got the shower was like come on do it
suck me do it I know a hot make up bars
he was 50 at the time when I was talking
to her I remember it being like you're
so hot and and she said she was him she
was no I she was a wardrobe and she was
doing his wardrobe in his house in his
closet and he just started making out
with her and I said did you he goes she
goes I did I did because it's one Arnold
and he's hot and what am I gonna do
I was like thank you for looking but so
Arnold just he's I you know to
especially when he's young you walk in a
room it's like her star let's go to
pumping iron like like you tell the
stories when pumping iron it's like it's
hot that's the way it went that vanity
and again it's like it's like him here's
the thing if everybody's if everybody's
if everybody's obliged and everybody's
consenting and everybody's like it's
like then but it doesn't matter because
it was such a stud he was a cyst called
living BRABUS base come on could there
be a better life when you talk about the
American Dream could there be a better
life dude the guy's name is
Schwarzenegger and he became a gigantic
movie star the Governor of California
became the governor California and
became [ __ ] mullet I'm mr. Olympia
starting another give me another married
lady yeah what are we talking about
immigrant an Austrian guy like coming
from its crate with a heavy accent yeah
I mean dude think about how ball early
have depleted how bald you have to be to
play a robot from the future that has a
[ __ ] Austrian accent it's like I mean
it's crazy and you know he didn't want
to start on this year can I see her it's
like you never went
why is he have an Austrian accent it's
oral it's rain but they said I was just
some on Howard Stern he's there on 2015
and he was talking about when he first
got a movie offer because he wasn't
Olympia and they made a movie offer and
yeah I'm not a I'm not an actor you know
right then he was still concentrated on
bodybuilding when he moved in America
yeah cuz you that was his main focus
yeah so he would go to acting class from
8 a.m. to basically all [ __ ] day then
at night do all his bodybuilding [ __ ]
ham and workout think about you think
out here things out like Ferrigno right
yeah two guys incredible shape one is
one one with charisma like to burn yeah
which is right yeah but but that idea of
what's achievable and what's it what's
possible if your drive is such yeah but
you know just has it like it's so like
use this bodybuilder and there's a how
many like there's no mr. Olympia now
that you put in a [ __ ] movie know if
you meet them they don't Arnold just has
it like I think you would have made it
whether
bodybuilding or not thank you meet on me
like oh well there's something magic too
by the way on it well I always said it's
like I said if it predators on I can see
I could see if I I've seen a forty
thousand times but I've seen Babette's
feast twice right if predators on you
have bleeds we can kill it
I see it's brilliant it bleeds a bunch
of McTiernan they're all out of their
minds it's the lady leathers all
weathers just wrapping himself Jesse
Ventura's Jesse Ventura's first movie
yeah I don't thought it was good he cuz
they go you took a huge risk putting
Jesse Ventura he goes well you know he I
knew he was did some wrestling and with
his physique yeah okay so he was Shane
black the writer is in that he's Jack
they were all was it ro Shane blacks in
in Shane Black is in predator kid he's
the kid that gets killed first when they
got shredded where the girl says the
girl says the jungle came to life and
took him that chases he's chasing the
girl and she gets away yes see it's
[ __ ] ever happen see that movie in
wait yeah I'll do that or is not three
there's Shane black that's crazy
yeah wrote wrote lethal weapon he was 24
years old oh wow I don't know I wrote a
letter to him when I was 18 he was like
25 he wrote me back it changed my life I
mean we saw you so cool I went to his
house I shot I shot something in this
house when I was doing MADtv and he has
a library a library of one of those a
pulp fiction Matt oh yeah those those
graphic novels he lives in the creepy
like rock Hudson's old houses are creepy
who's about it man he had a great a huge
head gardener Wilshire it's a big
compound the end of will five shot there
and it's kind of this weird little
Enclave yeah that's Ouisa yeah is that
is that considering a [ __ ] I think so
that last predator was [ __ ] dreadful
yeah the whole mall guy how dare you
dread what the [ __ ] were they thinking I
don't know dude I don't know it was
dreadful I watch it on a plane he
usually I'll deal with some [ __ ] and
I'm like this is what I go on to walk
out jump out yeah it's very strange it's
tough man it's like the best movie
you've seen in the past two years what
about a recreation though yeah I tell
you what fury road the last like Mad Max
fury road I thought was just dynamite
really first frame Black Widow with
with Tommy's and yeah just because
George Miller's assassin oh good draw it
was well done it was done who's hired
Tom Tom Hardy and Charlize hey Tito they
got a fist fight each other and the
reason why Tom doesn't talk is there's
parts in it now supposed to be there's
some I heard that that supposed to be
Charlize character but they Diana was
upset about it that's what starts Ami's
got some interesting stories our buddy
it's got a lot of interesting stories
about Tom Hardy from the war yeah yeah I
like Todd though Frank loves him I've
met Tom you know it's just listen you
know there's one of the greatest alive
right now I'm five nine and hangs traps
and and and you know like in times five
times five a 1:43 right Tom's not a big
guy he's playing Bain but everybody's
taking three and when he's worried he's
in any place Adam yeah and he plays
about him he's touchy he's a really good
actor thing he's awesome you know I mean
when he did here seaman Bronson
phenomena yeah I hear stories like
acting up uh you're gonna get I'm gonna
we're not doing that bull it's kind of
the same one I didn't I felt like the
Antonio Brown when you hear how terribly
has to work with Jesus coaches go
ammount man yeah I know he's Britain but
he's great though I know we'll find
someone else Rowan's financier can't
like glittery on that day Eagles team
destroyed their chances of winning San
Antonio Brown just a nightmare to deal
with so then the next time you see it's
gonna be on site oh that's the boozy cha
what's the name that he's the he's a yes
yes Clark
Ryan Clark Brian Clark but but Tom
Bosley cool it with the Tom Hardy what
did his job and Tom Hardy was uh I mean
we all knew when he was doing warrior we
knew I knew from Frank that CA was like
he's the new Prince we're gonna make him
a star we're already seeing dailies
going this guy he's just undeniable yeah
he's not a dick he's a really he's
actually really cool I think he's gonna
be a killer I mean it's not so his
success is not surprising yeah he did is
generally have so much talent yeah he's
a talented guy kills every role I
thought you'd want to Oscar for his
movie with Leonardo DiCaprio I thought
he was better than I just thought he was
I just thought it was too much it was
too much mumbling for her
we're Toby's version
yeah olio just I thought it was I
thought the gray was better and I spent
four hours talking to the director when
he was in prep on that movie - Henry -
yeah more hours talking about how to how
we made the gray what we did this that
the other thing I was only till the end
my buddies like the end they kind of
lifted from using yeah and I watched I
was like you too little it's a little
trickery there he's a talented dude man
Birdman's a great movie
yeah no no he said he's a talent a
talent a guy so fury road fury road and
then I'm thinking of like what some
other great movies and come out recently
I mean the marshlands just dominating
man yeah I don't I don't find those yeah
like I don't you know dig them
no to me that's not art that's just
that's uh that's a layup just slam dunk
but you know what it's like what you go
on State Warriors play bath way yeah
yeah here's the thing you watch you
think about 22 movies and what they're
able to kind of interweave through all
those films yeah but if it's been done
before right it's in the novel comics oh
no it's not they change it I guess they
stopped some of it but the ground works
those are foundations sure here and the
fanbase is there yeah especially 1836
males like the fanbase is there or they
want to show up that's yeah just just
make a cool I wish sometimes though that
people cared about this country as much
they care about Avengers in Game of
Thrones I really do just [ __ ] care a
little bit I just at least you know the
ending cuz everybody with Game of
Thrones do you know the good guy it's
gonna end win you know I mean now maybe
well maybe we'll see I just can't sir
you know I see dragons I'm out I've just
never been able to I'm never able to
Lord of that she's not that's how I was
then you watch it then you watch it I
just I don't know bigger Carly's right
just ry season one dragon stop me - I
[ __ ] hate dragon I see video - I was
like yeah it's like this is the Battle
of Helm's Deep and there'll be thousands
of awesome dribbles it's legal barriers
like [ __ ] to me dragons the Dragons are
a metaphor it's not actually our new
weaponry
okay the dragons in an audience rules
the dragons in arrrr an arms race it's
an arms race all I got [ __ ] it's the
Dragons are distracting oh I take it
back dragon plane a fire love rain of
fire Christian Bale where they're eating
ash that like they burn the whole world
and they eat ash dude random fire it
wasn't it with Matthew McConaughey
jumps up like a crazy man a [ __ ] good
movie abrecan's yeah rain are you bring
up cherry cobbler sailor bring up the
trailer that [ __ ] look at that look at
Macaulay God about just doing the
craziness combination boobie and
Christian Bale's in it damn man dude
yeah everybody should I think I brought
this [ __ ] up I made all this fire I'm
never gon [ __ ] this is actually going of
fire cat six years ago ten years ago
yeah a long time ago rain of fire this
was while 70,000 views
that's so weird it was ten years ago
touchstone it's not even around anymore
I think so spyglass not around anymore
this was a good movie noticed we
directed this dude oh that Rob Rob oh
god they got rid of this voice did they
you made a lot of money dude he's fine I
know he's living in Boca he's got a
little boat in Makati nobody knows but
they're awesome it's actually a good
movie it looks awful great actors what's
a guy do for a job the voice yeah we had
the same agent I see a very sad voice
that this guy is so outdated started
this to Dragon now all of us leave
follow me this summer Gila County my
kids called McGillicuddy couldn't save
Akane as if again if you work in the
comedy I've now written Akane
no he's a beast yeah alright another
another talented guy I mean you know I
think you know times crazier to
[ __ ] rat but you know that yeah
some of the best people are right yeah
but that's that move that's a dragon
movie should not be able to stand him
and now I like him from True detective
he's really great in true detective it
was really great to it tonight that I
kind of like changed about faced on
everything cuz I was just like he's so
vain right I'm like what are your shirt
off but then it's like [ __ ] it the guys
oh it go in good hands
I'm a person nothing but good things
firk with him by working with him they
say he's just the coolest [ __ ] he
really is no I mean I I've met him
socially but I've never I've never uh
yeah he's kind of under Annihilus but
but but see like ok so that's dragon but
I think it like the Lord of the Rings I
think of like literally three hours of
midgets running cross-country and aerial
shots and and then another battle and
then Viggo Mortenson and a dwarf versus
700 of these things I yes too much get
into it early dude that's its midgets
running cross it was my problem with
Lord there's just too long it's too long
yes three now the power sources Howard
source scores amazing and Peter
Jackson's a dude listen they're they're
technically brilliantly made films yeah
I just don't know any [ __ ] I mean I
think G ot you would like I agree okay
that was cool too the Benedict
Cumberbatch dragon that scene where he's
like he can smell you that was cool
okay another cool dragon thing I'm sorry
this kind of into dragon dragon alright
do do with James I don't [ __ ] with with
you know what's a good dragon crazy
gingers brought up Smaug that was cool
that way you know hold the drink oh by
the way bring up Benedict Cumberbatch's
motion capture performance you ever seen
that now what would that mean
Oh bro he's also a wildly talented guy
he really is man
oh yeah he's great the motion capture
for small yeah dude check that out this
is what Josh Brolin said I watched this
and this is what made me decide to play
Thanos in that in the Avengers I thought
I've turned into dads I thought if this
guy can do this right this is there it's
worth oh he's he's he's Shmi I'll watch
this no Watchmen I smell you I
right I find this embarrassing I know I
find this very embarrassing great voice
though
Brennan if you could play Brainiac in
Superman and they said you got to do but
I'm in there no no ready we need
tracking device no no the phone's fine
just track out this is it great please
and none can stop me no doubt you
purloined it but your filthy draw
friends I've actually said that line in
public her long as your filthy door
friends had nothing to do with this he's
such a good actor now show the actual
thing if you see the actual thing it's
wild I might be they are they that's
acting brother no that's a grown man
it's basically shifting he's doing
Shakespeare
he is dude no they didn't know this
smell and taste of dwarf no one better
let me tell you something bro that's
going on in and in he's that's going all
the best it bounced did they [ __ ] with
his voice they amplified his voice all
right they know dude that's his boy when
you see the real one yeah that's his
voice yeah I just I've seen this scene
so maybe Brenna's right doing a [ __ ]
thing with dragons but this is cool
I opened it's actually not an I know I
smell you cat or you know Lord of the
Rings I've never gotten around to
watching the series I never saw this no
cat you're young do you think Avengers
is like your Star Wars yes it is isn't
it yes it is my daughters are the same
thing but I don't like they're not in
the Star Wars the NewsHour's I realized
Iron Man 2 now is like that's your 10
years you guys are kids it's like that's
kind of how
I get it I'm rider again so my daughter
said something that you know is he under
this when does it start go until just
pop out I think I just wanna see I just
don't see the character Ian fast forward
chin is it's not here he goes sir yeah
he's fast but he pops up here it says
something this guy seems very casual and
I know that that ring makes him
invisible oh it is that right so this
was the part he was just playing yeah
that's pretty cool pretty cool do you
think you need to be on the ground like
that it's tough though for this okay
just stand here and go I feel you bro
the difference is what you just did
double scale what he did for million box
you gonna save da all their cold showers
edge it will give a double scale yeah
well forgot the dragon I mean do you
need to get on all fours like that God
is to be scared you're too old to be
scared of the dragon gold coins though
you know stop this gym before you take
up YouTube nice look that convinced josh
brolin to play that part he's like how
that guy can be you down for that I can
we okay there's something in it that's
not interesting that's what real acting
is I get such a kick out of it no I want
to be an actor have you ever seen how
you have to shoot a movie well if you're
playing a dragon but if most people saw
the way what an actor has to do like
those little detail but you guys did
that great those great sketch fine kid
but not when Shah was are the thing when
the agents would tell him like shut up
or they did or the casting be were
shutting yeah but that was great man I
did I thought that's great he had a we
had it wasn't Benedict Cumberbatch
rolling on the ground with motion but he
had his moment he has a double scale
moment right not bad at all but you know
you see people do some some pretty wacky
[ __ ] like you see people like yeah you
got a snake like listen Liam Neeson
tells great stories about like I don't
mind telling the story gives a [ __ ] he
told me a great story about Daniel
day-lewis and and I being on the being
on the set of me the greatest being
instead of like gangs New York and he's
my guys when the guys in character like
that right he said it kind of tends to
suck all the energy to this guy yes
so it's like you're you're like you know
and
and I think john c reilly they're all
the same hours ago what do we like
chopped liver because I'm not nobody
saying my character name or nobody's
saying and I think Daniel day-lewis
phenomenal nothing wrong with that but I
also think Liam is all right it's like
hey brah I'm gonna do my thing you do
your thing yeah I have that's not my way
and there and I think those things I
think harder you'll do that as well as
soon as soon as of what keep Phoenix
right where if you're calling him Arthur
and you can't call him you know hit by
his real name and also everybody's
walking on eggshells because he's not
saying hello or goodbye to anybody he's
just so there and just in his own world
it's like I know like I know like
Geraldo was sending like used rubbers
use Comcast and like went into a meeting
had this guy's Drake drop a pig on the
table Wow I'm gonna get home did this
you send me a use rubber I'm gonna come
knock on your trailer yeah that's weird
[ __ ] don't play Joker yeah jerilyn like
weird [ __ ] and so that's part of what
every what keep Phoenix it I think it
works I mean I don't give a [ __ ] what he
does if he's that good he's that good
yeah be that good you know listen you
know like you know that has to do well
you better hit a homerun you better hit
a home it's a it's like the guys in the
locker room that don't change their
jockstrap that's fine if you hit home
runs yes if your shitty player you we're
gonna dude you can't do that you can't
do you stinky what was it yeah you're
right it takes a lot of guts to do what
I only watched it for five days but that
takes a lot of guts and the ability to
suffer for dudes listen it does it also
doesn't because you're disappearing and
it's kind of a convenient way of saying
I'm gone I'm gonna go with it yeah I
don't use right on the front but you
know not to talk to me yeah you come to
age your energy like you're building
this veneer around you and listen I got
another guess if I had if I had an actor
it's like this is the way I want to play
the part I think would have to be a
discussion because I did I don't know it
almost gives them not used to be that
you know though pretty awesome because
at some point I go to him ago hey I
don't give a [ __ ] who you are right now
I'm gonna bash you with my [ __ ] elbow
yeah the Joker
yeah Jared or be somebody whatever you
want give a [ __ ] but you're one of you
in there is gonna be on the ground yeah
it's like but I just think it gets a
little [ __ ] precious pup like stop
yeah yeah you know I I agree but there
but then all the Sinise and all the all
the although it all does like all the
intellectually you said you gotta hit
home run let's go take a piss you got a
hit
let's go guys have our dicks let's do
some current events sounds good
what do you got chin first one is the
new Sonic the Hedgehog trailer did you
gather too old for I'm gonna wear
laughing chin so for guys my age is a
big deal because I was a Sega Genesis
dude see anything oh no major major oh
dude did you play a game as a kid no
nothing you don't play Madden or
anything no there was that wannabe
around never played a [ __ ] video game
in my life of it but Sonic is a big deal
but I haven't seen the training I got
really got really sick I got like a
weird pedo live tonight what I'm in it
would so when I'm in an arcade with my
son I'm shooting zombies or something or
I'm doing anything I get motion sick no
weird you'll see no you don't throw my
throat when it you're in Disney and
you're in the simulator thing with a
screen yeah he's coming at you I'll
throw up I almost threw up I had to
literally do it my son's like I'm like
this oh you have a thing do the 3d we
have we believe in green a [ __ ] yeah
have you done that Brian can you do 3d
or the five dates I can't do it for a
long time I if it's just a ride I'm fine
do they do they have Creed boxing on
there it's phenomenal
yeah it's good phenomenal yeah you're
there you're looking around and there's
Rocky Balboa behind it's great all right
hit it Jim let me see oh it's not a
cartoon it's held in real time is that
Jimmy Marsden yep oh this is a movie why
would they do it in real Clint oh [ __ ]
I'm kind of into these Pumas on always
like an alien or I think he is well that
was his bat the bet oh my god
[Music]
let's submit to I got a lot of time for
you carry a lot of [ __ ] dialyze Mars
favorite human I think it's kind of cool
for kids
yeah but my son's didn't grow up this
isn't for kids B this is for kids my
that we're the 18 year old 30 year olds
are the ones that know Sonic the
Hedgehog my son don't know he is yeah
but they still watch it there's my
friend girl teka teka
I love tika I mean [ __ ]
it's different I don't know I think it's
gonna be a hit
why they did why no no y-you see you
don't know you know it's interesting
that the uncharted you don't that's why
I decided to bring it up because have
you seen people online no it's just just
cuz it's just it looks like [ __ ] that's
why that looks awful why did they make
something it's really weird
you're the trade what didn't feel right
I want to show you guys really yeah yeah
yeah please let's look like that I don't
know I don't know if that's gonna be I
don't know because because that's that's
the early 90s generation you'll get but
my Uncharted games do the Uncharted yeah
they would play Sonic in the game hmm
so you never know man there's like which
one it this is not your one brother this
is everywhere on Friday at nine point
eight note the one down there the fuel
with all the bamboo this is this it's in
theaters not Netflix right now bro
theaters everywhere he was happy
the sky turns black the barrio that
things happen when the sky turns black
when we were kids we were told about the
legend
anytime you got hot in the hood you'd
hear those chopper pipes gangsters found
God had a fear the devil what that one
was he
cartel killed a bunch of police officers
coming to plant a flag in LA and reset
the game we never see anything like this
it's a war zone knew this was coming
what was coming revolution bingo
how's being straight with you I have to
tell you I'm not sure what to do next
George Lopez George Lopez out of your
mind what's good
now I have to do what's right I have to
become this it's the only way to protect
my city can you what do you see
rage
Diana
I've run the street
this is all-out war now to come 24 hours
in the dampers
I am neither right nor good I will make
up the difference
Hey damn dude by the way what's your
Connell the ghetto Grim Reaper six and a
half million dollar movie I raised 14
million dollars for everything shoot
that film everything even to put it out
olena everything you produce that he
paid for all that stuff uh because no
studio wanted it they all passed on it
Wow fifty percent of the tickets bought
in North America or the Latino audience
and they passed so there's a lot riding
on it scam yeah yeah well you know how
it does like write a Saturday Saturday
yeah and you know what's funny I like I
just don't want to like I don't want I
want to step away from it because I'm
the guy that like you watched it like
I'm sure you guys like the come on it's
like you get like brother you really
complicated well here's some reviews of
the show II just stay away from that
because you just dive down this you know
it's just a dirt with uh so you know
Saturday leap but it's good time he's
come out with the Avengers and no
brother by the way I'm hope you want to
believe with that well but did the first
weekend but listen we're going targeted
targeted targeted like markets like
we're going into heavily heavily Latino
who is producing who is a what's the
studio Briarcliff which is Tom Warren
burger the only studio chief that won
Best Picture Oscars at two different
places you want for crash at Lionsgate
in 2016 when it's for spotlight for open
road which released the gray so you know
yeah they all pass there'll be said no I
know that guy he was a stunt guy
it's from Ben Bray yeah a great guy yes
that's yeah okay um and so yeah there's
that looks great I'm hoping so you can
go CF theaters nationwide Friday Friday
Friday is de três they're right here
anything [ __ ] in on that I think that's
a good remote the movies anymore no more
Ferrari talk no more chicks badasses and
know that Walt's fat is in great movies
and great movies business Brendon
schedule yeah Tampa Brendon chop Tampa
next week Friday Saturday up them in
Cleveland get your tickets tak calm
there you go
Miami may 9 10 11 it's my birthday there
see me come see me Orlando May 17-18
Indianapolis June 6 7 8
chief @k calm well we appreciate you man
thanks guys you're the best go see his
movies appreciate us pal this Friday
it's Friday no no no chicken oh this is
the fun kid we're out